so we're super grateful to my organizers
but especially Alex oh
thank you
thank you and also say thank you so much
to all the organizers and to the center
staff
um
great so Kevin started with the paper
robust that secretly didn't have a
network and I will tell you about a
paper verse that does actually have a
network uh and so this is about how
networks matter for data and social
learning
and so right
um let me start with a sort of broad
description of the type of social
learning setting that we've seen
earlier in this conference we have a lot
of Agents they're learning about some
unknown state
they're all going to have some private
information about the state and they're
also going to observe some
uh neighbors actions and so we're going
to be particularly interested in
settings where you don't necessarily
observe everyone else who might be
acting or sort of everyone possible and
the main question that we're going to
ask is How does the structure
of The Social Network
or the observation Network affect how
efficiently information is aggregate so
I think with this audience I can jump
into some of what's known about this
there's a lot of theoretical work on
Bayesian social learning on the complete
Network so settings where in some sense
you see all the other agents or everyone
who you could possibly see
there's some nice work on
um Bayesian social learning on networks
that says eventually in many settings
agents learn the state on all networks
that are reasonable in some sense and
I think some of you know these results
I'll tell you what this means formally
if you don't later on
but the takeaway from this is that
there's less known about how Bayesian
social learning Compares across Networks
and if we want to ask the question the
main things that we're going to have to
ask about is not sort of long run
learning but in some sense how well
signals are aggregated or how quickly
rational agents learn and so we saw a
version of this in Omarion case paper
yesterday this is going to be a
quite different model but
um similar sort of questions
to somebody
um and so just as a little backup for
this being something that people are
interested in here's a quote from a
survey by Ben and Evan that says a
significant Gap in our knowledge
concerned short run Dynamics and rates
of learning and what these models mean
here is
Bayesian models of social learning and
networks
and so let me tell you what we do about
this we introduced what we think is a
tractable model of rational social
learning
that lets us compare learning across
different networks and in particular
we'll get a measure that will let us
rank many networks with respect to their
efficiency for social learning
the main sort of obstruction to learning
that we're going to be looking at is
what I'll call network-based
informational compounds and so let me
give you a simple example of this it
could be that I see Alex and Nicole take
actions they both
observe Rachel taking an action but I
don't see Rachel
in this case from my perspective
Rachel's action is going to confound the
behavior that I see Alex
and Nicole taking
and so even if I'm rational and I can
account for this I may not do as well as
if I saw what uh Rachel had chosen to do
and so these types of intransitivities
are going to appear in many Networks
and we're going to see it turns out it's
not too bad in this case but in some
other examples these intransitivities
can lead to arbitrarily inefficient
social learning
and one class of networks that we think
demonstrate this nicely are what we'll
call Generations networks where agents
arrive in successive cohorts and each
cohort observes the cohort before them
or some of the cohort before them
in these Generations networks under some
symmetry condition we'll be able to
express the rate of learning as a simple
function of some Network parameters that
I'll tell you about
and one of the implications of that
formula is going to be that almost all
of the information is lost so under the
Symmetry condition learning is going to
aggregate no more than two signals worth
of information
per generation asymptotically I'll tell
you what that means formulation but the
the takeaway here is that these
Generations may be large they could have
a hundred or a thousand people each each
of these people is getting their own
private signal
but the learning from one generation to
the next is going to lose almost all of
the signals it's only going to get you
in the best case a bit under two signals
worth of information
okay great so
I won't say I don't want to spend too
much time on the literature but let me
just say there's some a class of nice
papers that find in various ways Network
structure doesn't matter too much for
sort of outcomes like long run learning
there's also a lot of interest in
comparing networks and different types
of social learning models
um but this usually
most of the existing results are either
say comparing two networks or doing
numerical simulations in settings where
it's hard to get analytic results and so
we'll tell you about a framework where
we can get some analytic rankings of
broader classes of Networks
there's also some newspapers I guess one
of which
we saw yesterday on other obstructions
to the efficient learning rate like
course actions where my action doesn't
fully
reveal my belief or endogenous
information acquisition we'll ask some
similar questions to these literatures
but we'll ask it uh then we'll ask
another setting where we abstract away
from these other obstructions and the
obstructions are really just coming from
Network structure and that's what
determines whether you learn better or
worse
okay so let me
tell you the model
um it's all on this slide there's two
equally likely States
Omega is either zero or one it's a
sequential model so agents arrive one at
a time
they're each going to
observe a private signal I'll tell you
how that works soon
they'll observe the actions of some
neighbors and then they'll choose to act
and then after they take their action
they're done they're gone from the model
and somebody else arrives
these neighborhoods are going to
determine the network structure so the
neighbors are the set of people before
me who I see and so we can think of this
as defining an observation structure if
we know who each person sees that's
going to together give us a network
what are they going to do with this
information they're going to pick an
action that's
a real number between zero and one and
they're going to want to minimize the
square distance from the state and so
it's standard that this implies that
their action is just going to be equal
to the probability that the state is one
given their information
um
but then the ages move in order does
that is that Network dependent the order
in which they move or is it just you're
just gonna any order of Agents so I'm
kind of confused between them moving in
order and the and the network yeah so
what's the right way so you can think we
fix an order of agents and then we
Define a network
on this
um agents in this order with the
condition that you can only observe
people who came before you so this is
equivalent I guess to the network being
a direct today's cyclic graph given that
the order doesn't
really matter you could think of having
some set of Agents with a network before
the order and then if you want to
translate that into this you could say I
observe the people who I have things to
move before me okay and so we're not
going to think about how
you go back and forth between those two
networks but that's something you can do
and there's some other work on
great and so what's really going to be
important for everything other than sort
of the welfare where we need an actual
utility function is that the action
space is Rich enough to reveal building
so the action I choose reveals my
beliefs about the state
the maybe most substantive assumption we
make is that signals are gaussian and
conditionally IID given the state what
does that mean in this binary State
setting
if the state is
if the state is one the signals are
going to be gaussian with the mean of
one and some variance
if the state is minus one they're going
to be guessed sorry zero they're going
to be guessed in with the mean of minus
one and the same variance so what's this
going to imply if I see a positive
signal the state is more likely to be
positive to be one than zero the more
positive it is the more likely it is to
be one and conversely a negative signal
implies the states more likely to be
zero the lower the signal the stronger
the beliefs
the neighborhoods are so the network
structure is common knowledge and agents
are Bayesian and choose optimal actions
given observations and predecessors play
so you can think this is National
equilibrium but there's nothing
strategic and so you don't really need
that
um
since this is the whole model happy to
take questions but I'll I'll just give
you a minute more to see it and I'll
comment on I think a lot of this uh
everything here is assumptions that
sometimes appear in this literature
the two that are not the most common are
these continuous actions and the
gaussian signals and what we're going to
see is that the combination of these two
assumptions leads to some nice
properties that let us say things about
the model
uh this is an answer
the expectation is the payoff this
distance negative distance from the
state
thank you
okay great so let me get into
what's nice about this model and
um then tell you about a couple of
examples
so
the first nice property which some of
you might expect given the gaussian
structure is that we're going to get
linear actions in some sense and so to
see this we're going to need to work in
a space of log likelihoods and so I can
turn each signal into a corresponding
log likelihood that the of the state
being 1 and turn each action into a log
likelihood of the state being one that
would rationalize that action
these are by objective changes and so we
can think of the actions or strategies
as being mappings from
your log signal and your neighbor's log
actions to your log action and so the
first result says this map is linear
this is coming from the gaussian
information structure and so formally my
log action is equal to my log signal
plus some weighted
combination of my neighbor's log actions
and these weights are going to depend on
the network structure the proof gives an
explicit formula for them I won't tell
you that now but what you can think is
if two act two neighbors actions
are more correlated I might down weight
them if somebody's action is more
accurate then I might upgrade it and put
more weight on it and there's a formula
that tells us how to do this
I'll maybe also mention this is coming
from the gaussian signal structure it's
maybe not for exactly the same reason as
usual and so it turns out to be because
of this nice fact that with a binary
State and this got a stand signal
structure I told you about the log
likelihoods are also distributed as
conditionally gaussian random variables
and so given that you can get this and
so it's from gaussian but for assertive
not exactly the same reason as in most
keep us updated it's almost like
sure it's almost like
a degree bottle uh I guess there's
no way to think about whether the
weights are signature right press it
certainly across people they're not kind
of right but um
let's go Alexa the way it turned on this
yeah okay so this is something that
might not surprise you too much
another feature of this model that did
surprise us more is that we can
interpret the accuracy of an agent's
action in terms of an equivalent number
of independent private signals that
you'd have to get
to take the same action so what do I
mean by that
well first of all if somebody just got
an independent private signals it turns
out that their action would take
this form it would be normal with this
distribution don't worry too much about
the details of this these constants are
coming from this transformation from the
signals to the log likelihoods which
were also gaussian but with some other
distribution but
what I want you to think is this is if I
see an independent signals my action is
gaussian with some fairly simple
distribution
I'm going to say social learning
Aggregates our signals by agent I if
their log action
has this distribution for some real
number R and so what I'm doing is I'm
taking
the distributions that you get if you
see an independent signals for any n and
I'm interpolating between the integer
values of n
something to highlight about this is if
agents take arbitrary actions even if
their actions are log linear and so we
still have all this normal structure
this condition doesn't have to hold it's
proposing a particular restriction on
how the mean and the variance
of their action distribution relate in
general they could be taking actions
that would lead to sort of all sorts of
normal distributions with all sorts of
mean and variances
um
and so they don't and the actions that
they could take even if they were doing
something nice and linear don't have to
have this form
the reason this is useful is the
rational log actions always
satisfy this definition they always
admit this type of signal counting
interpretation
and so formally what this is saying is
that there's some integers RI such that
social learning Aggregates RI signals by
agent I
it turns out these depend on the network
but not on the signal structure
and so
the reason this is useful well there's a
couple of reasons but the main reason
this is useful is that these rois give a
sufficient statistic for the accuracy of
a rational agent's action so in general
their actions are going to if we didn't
have this their action would be some
distributions it's sort of a pain to
compare one agent's action distribution
to another with this if we want to ask
say is one agent learning better on one
network than another we can just compare
these sufficient statistics we can ask
is the ri smaller for that agent on one
network than the other
foreign
we can measure each agent's accuracy in
units of independent private signals
these are signals
um
exactly I mean I guess what surprising
is
the first argument necessarily an
integer why will the
if you have an actual integer number you
can't it doesn't make sense to have one
private signals we're just going to
interpolate to Define one map private
Signal's worth of information States
what is it
like yeah yeah so right so everything is
conditional on the state so what this is
saying is it has this situation with the
plus here if the state is one and a
minus here if the state is negative one
um and last question when you like the
variance being exactly what it is I mean
our Peoria could have been that it
wouldn't look anything it wouldn't look
like that for the meaning variance would
be related in that way so I guess
it's the results it's a bit magical to
us so I don't have like you know
we prove it I don't have a real coming
interpretation like tribulous and we
don't think it's trivial it's yeah yeah
it's
um you can any like more generic you
know if you're too standing there the
British rule then it's going to be nice
so
let me give some examples that are going
to show you how the signal counting
interpretation works and also what these
contents in our model that I promised
you looked like and so let me start with
a simple example that I told you
verbally in the introduction with four
agents
agent one gets a signal that says the
state's more likely to be one they take
an action that corresponds to that two
and three arrive they don't see anyone
so they also get their signals and take
the right actions given that
and then four arrives C's two and three
and
has to figure out what to do with their
signal and these two signals they
observe and in this setting because
everything is
the whole setup of the model including
the network structure is common
knowledge
agent four can back out
two and threes private signals from
their actions
and so agent four is
action is going to be equivalent to if
they knew three independent private
schools in fact they do know three
independent private signals and so they
can optimally combine
two three and four signals because they
can calculate off yeah
maybe you should finish the examples
yeah
so what happens now
if two and three
observe one now four has this problem
where four C is two and three
but doesn't see agent one's signal or
action that's influencing both of their
actions
and it turns out that they can't fully
incorporate two and three signals
without over counting ones they face
this inevitable trade-off between over
counting overweighting one signal and
underweighting two and three signals
they're abasian so they're going to deal
with this trade-off as well as they can
it turns out the optimal signal
extraction
underweights two and three signals
somewhat overweights one signal somewhat
and ends up
with an R4 of three and two-thirds so
they're doing as well as if they had
three and two-thirds independent signals
worth of information
this is in fact better than if they had
no access to agent one Sigma it's not
too bad but there is some information
last year they're losing a third of us
um I'll take this question and then I'll
show you that this can get much worse
usually the mean and the standard
deviations
yeah experience after they come as
variance right
yeah
distribution well so if I see an
independent signals then the variance is
going to scale linearly and then right
by this Independence right so should the
mean be two over Sigma or Sigma squared
uh it should be Sigma squared uh I'm not
going to build it
recreate this uh we create this
calculation on the board but I'm pretty
sure that uh
it's yeah these constants are both
coming from this change from the signals
to the log likelihoods and it turns out
that they come in and sort of the same
Dimension from that but
um yeah this is right and like fairly
sure but I
um
but I don't remember the details okay
uh
so should I be thinking of r as some
kind of signal to noise ratio
um
[Music]
[Music]
it's in some sense in column informative
business action right
that's the key information about
so yeah and sense in the set yeah I
don't think in the sense that right it's
it's a measure of informativeness which
you can think of as being about signal
to noise I don't know if that's signal
no no it's in any sense I'd be happy to
talk about it more of it I don't know if
it's ignore the noise in any sort of
more formal sense than that
Okay so
are you gonna
okay so can you go over again this bit
about the um trade-offs that P4 the hf4
has just you were saying that they they
have a trade-off between underweighting
yeah uh maybe I can make so they're
going to
observe two actions which are going to
be
and
they're they're gonna know these two
things uh is this this is the wrong
story what do I call is it Linda
they know the actions right go ahead
keep going Uh Kevin what do I call them
okay great uh
organization oh that's no longer here
okay so they're gonna see the sum of the
log likelihoods at a corresponding to
these two signals which they come back
out from this section and the sign of
the log likelihoods corresponding to
these two signals which correspond to
theories action and so they're going to
choose some weights it turns out by
symmetry they're the same but they're
going to take fill that on their signal
Plus
some weights on
these two things that they see and so
what's going on here is they would like
to put the same weight on Lambda one and
then three but there's no way to you can
choose that'll do that whatever they do
oh I see okay
um but all right thanks
very I guess in fact they'd want to put
weight one on each of these four but
there's no no way to do that
great so I told you this can be my twist
let's
stick with the sort of same setup but
add more patients and so now we're going
to have three generations of different
sizes
these
this top generation of Agents doesn't
see anyone so they just report their
signals the second generation sees
everyone in the first generation and
then there's one final agent who sees
the second generation
and
what we get here what we can calculate
it turns out really all you need from
this is that you can get this from that
signal counting interpretation
um is that the change in accuracy
between Generations two and three
there's equivalent to getting this many
private signals this
quantity here and whatever K and K Prime
is however big these Generations are
the change in accuracy between the
second generation and the third is less
than three additional signals so these
RIS are going up by less than three
there's little change in accuracy
there's very little learning between
Generations two and three and it turns
out that this is
true even if K is small and so this
bound this three bands would hold for
example even if there is only one person
in the first generation
uh
uh but not if there's zero not if
they're zero right so if you had a
thousand people in the second generation
if there were no one in the first
generation then that's great they just
all tell you the signals and you get a
thousand and one signals worth of
information but if they all just saw one
person
and took the optimal action given that
one person then you would do much worse
I think you you would get less than five
signals worth of information and so
almost all the information
this is different from what was going on
still more stock yesterday it's not that
these people aren't incorporating the
private signals that are just
looking at Old information that said
I think they just can't back out the
information
yeah I think that's it so yes
um and then particular this is very
dependent they had a gun that was
independent of network structure and we
call it for any strongly connected
Network I guess design exactly connected
because they can't be in our setting but
this is very dependent on the network
structure so if you put one thing if you
had one person there if you put one link
from this person to the first person
then everything is okay so this is
saying some networks it's a much less
much worse than others
that certain types of network structures
can generally
tons of time but maybe I can tell you if
I could use some examples this is a lot
of the attrition for one of the main
courses but maybe I can tell you
something about what happens on sort of
non-finite Networks
so
the first question we can ask if we want
to go beyond finite networks is when do
we get long run learning
and so I'll say Society learns
completely in the long run if actions
converge to the true State and
probability and this turns out to be
equivalent to these RIS the equivalent
number of independent signals converging
to Infinity
and so the result here is going to be
Society learns completely in the long
run if and only if the index of an
agent's most recent
neighbor converges to Infinity this is
equivalent to a condition that some of
you have seen it's called expanding
observations in this paper by us some of
their own co-authors
um
so I don't want to spend too much time
on this because many of you may know it
but it's
mild and clearly necessary if this fails
then there's some kind of set of Agents
such that infinitely many agents only
observe Agents from that finite set
that
um
means you can learn because if you have
internet many agents with only finite
access to finitely many signals there's
no way to learn
what this is saying is that there's
fairly necessary condition this sort of
necessary obstruction to Long Run
learning is the only one so
as long as this
um as long as this sort of natural
obstruction doesn't fall if you do get
long-run learning this is harder to
prove in
the model in this paper I cite but it
turns out to be fairly straightforward
in this model because our actions are
continuous
but so the takeaway from this is that
we get long-line learning and almost all
reasonable networks and so it's not a
very useful Criterion
for asking questions about which network
circuits they're learning
instead of Criterion that we find is
useful in many examples is what I'll
call aggregative efficiency which is the
limit of our I override and so what this
is is what fraction of the signals in
the entire Society do individuals
aggregate under social learning so if
I'm the 100th
individual RI over I is
all right is I'm taking an action
equivalent to if as good as if I knew RI
private independent signals so all right
over I is I'm doing as well as if I knew
what fraction of the signals that have
arrived so far and we're going to ask
what does this look like in the long run
what fraction of all the signals in the
long run are getting sort of
incorporated into social life
because you can have
yeah so the direct neighbors are sort of
not enough because you can learn
indirectly from other people if I see
somebody and they see someone else I can
learn from them you could something you
could do instead that sort of is divided
by the number of people who there's an
indirect path to religion it turns out
these things are going to be the same in
the examples I look that but if you
think there's sort of a lot of physical
constraints where I don't see a lot of
people in the network then you might
want to sort of do something more subtle
that accounts for how many people I can
reach but this is just a simple measure
that works
um
nicely in many states
and so something to point out here is we
can have
long run learning this RI going to
Infinity but RI over I
uh near zero or even equal to zero so we
can be getting there very slowly there
and quite efficiently even when we're on
this big class of networks where we're
eventually
um in the paper I want
go through this now because this is a
short day time we showed that higher
aggregated efficiency implies higher
wealth networks like you have higher
aggregative deficiencies
give higher welfare if the welfare
function is sufficiently patient and if
signals are not too precise
so signals are very precise you might
have sort of all the welfare happening
in the first all everything that matters
for welfare more or less happening in
the first few agents and you might need
to look at what's really going on in the
finance network if signals are not too
precise you can look at this measured as
which networks lead to higher with it
yeah is the fact that agents are only I
think once
[Music]
they're trying to think sort of compare
between this paper and filmers yesterday
um I think it's so I think it's really
coming
yeah I was trying to think about we were
talking to Maurice about this yesterday
uh
I think what's important for it is that
the balance that we give these these our
eyes are independent of the signal
precision and so we had this problem in
the paper yesterday where essentially if
you changed any of the parameters you
might change the sort of time until the
results kick in but I don't know I was
talking about in response to some of the
questions and the fact that we had this
Independence of the information
structure means there's a parameter that
we can change that sort of makes the
limit matter without changing the time
until our results kick in and so I think
that's the
um
I really don't have too much time but
let me
wear this five to ten minutes comparing
networks for social learning by
comparing their
aggregate image
um
and so I promised you these Generations
networks I'll at least have some time to
tell you about what we call maximal
Generations networks which are networks
where agents arrive in successive
cohorts and observe everyone in the
previous cohort so everyone in each
generation T each generation has size
head you can think these are like
different classes of the University or
cohorts of the firm everyone in
generation T observes everyone in the
previous generation and so here's an
example with three agents per generation
four and five and six I'll say one two
three seven eight nine two four five six
and so on
I just want to tell you that you have 11
to 12 minutes left amazing okay well
maybe you'll get to here
um so in these maximal Generations
networks we can give a fairly complete
description of learning outcomes
the first thing here's an expression for
the aggregated efficiency it turns out
to be 2K minus 1 over K squared what
does this tell us well one thing is it
that tells us is in the long run social
learning Aggregates fewer than two
signals per generation with any K so
this is this point I made at the
beginning even if the generations are
large
we're only getting
one and a half or one and three quarters
or 1.9 signals where I put information
even if there's a thousand or ten
thousand signals arriving in each
generation
you can ask how things
depend on the generation size so
um yeah let me put both of these there's
fewer signals
aggregated per agent
with larger K but more signals
aggregated progeneration with larger K
what does this mean well if you want to
ask our larger Generations header
you can ask a couple of questions you
might ask
if I'm the 100th person would I rather
have larger smaller Generations
the answer there is smaller because the
larger Generations generate this
confronting
you can also ask if I'm in the 100th
generation do I want larger or smaller
Generations
the answer there is larger is a bit
better because it's just more signals
that have arrived that I can access but
what this is saying is that I lose
almost all of that information so
there's not very much benefit even if I
know I'm in the 100th generation having
been bigger Generations before me only
helps a lot
those who are preparing across different
both both people were in the 100th
generation or did I was that right yeah
uh so I did two things the first was
you're the 100th person how big you want
all the generations today I got it for
that one you want the generations to be
small and intuition is that other
Generations are size one
then you can see there's no information
plus there's no contents the other one
sorry the suspect was if you're in the
100th generation you want bigger
Generations because it's just more
signals whatever at a time you show up
but it doesn't have to be very much
we can also get a sugar rundown which
says that after generation 2 social
learning Aggregates fewer than three
signals per generation with anything so
these two signals per generation is the
long run bound here it's saying after
the first two generations
we can get a band that's only slightly
worse
um and this sort of comes from the
example that I showed you
so yeah let me tell you a little bit
more about how we can think about
these bounds
the first thing that we can see is
social learning has to aggregate at
least one signal per generation
the that's because I can always take my
private signal to some action I see and
optimally combine them and I'll do one
signal better
what the lower bound is saying what the
sorry what the upper bound is saying is
that this lower bound is not too far
from the actual lift
we might do better than one signal per
generation but in the long run no better
than two and even in the short run after
the first two generations no better
and again it's the generations I learned
this is saying we're aggregating from
the an unboundedly small fraction of the
private signals
let me tell you a little more
information from this some of this might
have shown up earlier but it's this the
basic force behind this is the same
trade-off
between
um
between overweighting generation T's
private signals and underweighting the
common social information that came
before and
the idea behind this result is that when
the generations are large the optimal
action severely underweights
the private signals from generation C
and so in this example here you're under
waiting a bit as these Generations get
alert you're under waiting very severely
and so I guess we will see this later
but it turns out from the proof
that the total weight on private signals
from a generation T approaches one as T
goes large this is much less than you
would like you would like to be putting
weight one on each of the private
signals but instead you're putting a
total weight of one on quality
okay so I'll do this verbally
um how long do I
have a few minutes okay so
yeah let me tell you in the last couple
of minutes a little bit about how other
types of networks compare and so
question just to get yeah so if you
threw in some naive agents here that
where I broke some links so that they
didn't see anything
I'm trying to think of how much that
would help or the problem is you'd have
to have very specific patterns of them
over time
yeah good so yeah we had some discussion
of distance conversation at the paper
and
so roughly if you if you have some
people who say only observe their
immediate credit uh
let me do this one when I talk about
other networks but you could have some
people who say observe you could have
lines of people who observe sort of the
person in the same position in the
previous generation but no one else
they're not going to be subject to any
confounding and so you can make one
person or a few some of the people do
better
um by sort of sacrificing some of the
other people and so
depending on sort of what your welfare
function is whether people in certain
positions matter more than others um
you could leverage them heavily right so
you've got lots of people who serve them
people have lots of people and so if you
have a lot of people where you don't
care if they're learning badly then
um you can have the other people do much
better but there's what we think is
basically a conjecture is that the only
way that asymmetry can help get around
this band is by
sort of totally sacrificing some people
to help others you can sort of do
calculations with people and on the
optimal version
[Music]
but so yeah let me just
a question that we go on to ask in the
paper is what if you have other types of
network structures so we're going to
keep this generation structured they're
going to say what if you don't see
everyone in the previous generation
and so here's an example
um
on the left is this maximal Generations
Network we've seen on the right is a
network where everyone has seized two
neighbors but not the third person in
the previous generation so the first
person sees the first two the second
person sees the second and third and the
third seats in the first
and so you might wonder which of these
are better for
um or better for social learning
and I think it's not obvious because the
left hand Network gives more
observations people just have more
information on the other hand it has a
lot more overlap and so there's more of
this kind of happening
uh
um and so to answer this we need an
expression for aggregated efficiency on
more General Networks
I think
running out of time so I won't really
tell you how that works but what I will
tell you is we can get an expression
under a symmetry condition for the
aggregative efficiency in terms in
settings where agents have the same
degree and have the same number of
common Neighbors
take away from a couple of takeaways
from this first of all it turns out that
this aggregative efficiency is
uh less than 2 over K this term in
parenthesis is less than two and so this
generalizes
our amount of aggregating at those two
signals per generation to any of
these sort of symmetric Networks
um again it wouldn't hold if you did
what that suggested but if you had this
symmetry you're not going to do better
than this
and you can also make comparisons about
how the aggregative efficiency depends
on these different fragments so
let me go back to this uh that goes out
a bit fast but it turns out plugging
into this formula these two networks
give the exact same aggregative
efficiency
the extra social observation on the left
exactly cancels out the reduced
information content from the overlap
investors
so let me wrap up all uh since this has
been
a long day we told you about what we
think is a model of rational sequential
living that's helpful for
analytically calculating how social
networks affect
how well information is aggregate it
in general the network structure can
lead to confounding
and in certain types of networks
including many of these Generations
networks we looked at this confounding
can be quite severe and you can end up
losing investor almost all of the
information
thank you so much
questions so I guess following up on
that last question it it seems like you
could try to sprinkle sacrificial Lambs
around to help but one could maybe
summarize for points you're finding by
saying that indirect social work insofar
as social learning is genuinely indirect
that part is very slow If you sprinkle
in some direct learning opportunities
but the compound they get seems
compounding supplies when indirect
observations what I'm trying to
aggregate information from people I
don't directly see yeah so what I was
trying to say I don't know if everyone
what I was trying to say in about is a
structure that does well for some people
is if you have a bunch of these things
where there's no confounding
and then maybe this person over here
sees all these people I'm so
uh
you can get some you can sort of have
some sacrificial lens can still have
alas on indirectly because
that you really need this sort of
intransitivities but
um
The Sims yeah we sort of think this is
probably the best you can
yes
but it seems that
efficiency right
too smart
not like if they were assume
this is even worse so we have another
version where they think everyone's
actions are just their independent
private signals
um
and there you don't even necessarily get
long run learning you get convergence to
run at least with positive probabilities
um
one thing that does help is if people
put more weight on their private signals
if they sort of which you might think
you know it's a negative thing to do but
it's socially beneficial if I put more
weight than this privately optimal on my
private signal that's going to sort of
depolarly my action from other people's
actions and help the people who observe
it and so we have some results about
that
and I guess that's something that sort
of observed in behavioral economics
that's a real effect
thanks everybody good thank you
foreign